okay we're going to be looking today at
copper and this is something that
looking back in the old video they it's
a short video and there is an
experimentation in it so I thought we'd
do something a bit practical copper is
an element which people are very
familiar with because it's such a
characteristic colored metal sort of
reddish color though it gets darker when
oxide forms but it's quite a soft metal
and you can cut it quite easily if you
have a cutter like this that has steel
blades it will just dig in to the metal
and it should just cut off when you cut
the metal you get this very nice shiny
fresh surface color just like copper
this is a ball of copper copper metal
it's quite as you might imagine it is a
ball of metal in it so therefore it is
quite dense and heavy I mean it's not
not as dense as I think Steve told me
this morning if we had a ball of this
this size of plutonium he told me a bit
way about kilo and a half so he thought
and so it's not quite as heavy as that
but it's still pretty heavy and dense so
this is a very very very nice sample of
very fine copper wire so the copper wire
here is what width is this this is point
I'm not going that's just too too small
so it's point one of a millimeter
okay so inside the beaker we've got a
solution called
sodium potassium tartrate so no copper
in there at the moment we're going to
introduce that through this this is a
solution of copper sulfate copper is
very popular for architectural route use
because if you put it on the roofs of
buildings it then reacts particularly
with carbon dioxide in the air to give a
very nice green color first of all
though we need to heat this to about 50
degrees C and to the sodium potassium
tartrate we need to add some very weak
hydrogen peroxide so this is only 3%
hydrogen peroxide so it goes we need to
make sure they mix together which is why
there's a stirring bar at the bottom
there stirring away yes what
okay so stirring nicely so as I said
sodium potassium tartrate and hydrogen
peroxide and we need to add only one mil
so that's one centimeter cubed of the
copper sulfate that a copper wire here
is very very high-grade this is grade
one copper wire and it's 0.1 of a
millimeter in diameter and you can see
the wonderful copper has lustre coming
off the side there what do you mean by
grade one copper so this is very very
high purity this is like 99.99% copper
used for electronics fabrications and
high quality research samples it's also
used for electrical wiring in fact it's
used so much that in a country like the
UK each person has about 175 kilos of
copper associated with each person in
the piping the wiring and so on the
problem is that in many other countries
for example in China people have very
much less copper associated with them
there isn't so much electrical wiring in
rural parts of China and if everybody in
China had the same amount of copper
associated with them as those in England
or America or Canada there wouldn't be
enough copper in all the known deposits
around the world pop was actually
necessary for life plants and animals
use copper but actually you can have a
disease called Wilson's disease which
basically your body can't metabolize
copper properly it's actually an
inherited disease okay ready
what's going on there is it's producing
a lot of gas so it's reacting to form a
complex and it's going from the
potassium tartrate complex there - well
it's producing carbon dioxide and oxygen
mainly oxygen gas is being produced
which is why you're seeing the fizzing
and it's become copper oxide cuprous
oxide actually copper is found as a
metal lying around in various places in
the world I believe the name came from
the island of Cyprus in the middle of
the Mediterranean but copper has always
been known even in prehistoric times
people found small amounts of copper but
as we use more and more copper people
have had to dig deeper and deeper mines
the mine in Chile where those very brave
miners were entombed for more than two
months and then rescued was a copper
mine and to get the metal that we need
we're going to have to go deeper and
deeper and deeper into the earth so what
we've got in there now is is cuprous
oxide so that's copper one oxide and
it's actually gone from what was a kind
of clear see-through all right it's got
color on it let's see through solution
so something that's very cloudy so what
we've got there is a precipitate of the
copper oxide copper is very good because
it has very high thermal and electrical
conductivity what that means is that
heat flows through it very well and also
electricity if you make wires for
electrical transmission out of copper
when the electricity goes through them
you get very much less heating than if
you say made the metal they then say if
you made the wires out of iron and all
this heating is of course lost energy
you do even better if you made the wires
out of silver but Silver's too expensive
okay so let's see if we can change this
reaction back so at the moment it
started out as being about fifty it's
now shot up to 63 I imagine it was even
hotter than that when it originally
changed color so we'll see if we can
take it back back in I actually bought
this from the British Geological Survey
which is just down the room from here is
it in key worth I think and I just saw
this and it was a Christmas present for
my husband and I picked it out I just
think this is really cool actually
what did your husband think of getting
that as a Christmas present you know is
what I'm like so he buys these things we
he knows I'm a bit of a magpie I like to
collect shiny shiny things pretty things
that's my copper so the chakal is
gradually changing it's gone from orange
in our kind of a murky yellow you can
see it's kind of green now and again a
gradual change it wasn't a sudden
spontaneous straight back to being blue
and see-through you know clear it's now
now we've got back to that kind of clear
solution and again you can see on the
stir bar all the bubbles of the oxygen
little bit of co2 forming on that most
organisms you and me use iron in our
blood to transport oxygen that's what
makes our blood rate but in some sorts
of crustacean crabs and Simmel lobsters
they're different they use copper they
use a compound called hemocyanin it's a
blue compound of copper cyan is some
classical word for blue so they really
had blue blood and these hemocyanin uses
two atoms of copper in each molecule to
transport the oxygen around the body of
the crab or Lobster it's not nearly as
good as hemoglobin so if you start
running after tribal lobster it quickly
gets tired compared to running after a
rabbit or something like that which can
keep going faster than you can